Before we say goodbye, let's play a quick round of-
Drewth or dare.
(audience cheers and claps)
All right, we have Malik.
Hi Malik.
Hi!
All right, truth or dare?
Truth or dare, what is the most random thing we might find
in either of your closets?
I bought a pair of boots once.
It was after a happy hour where it was like,
"Oh yeah, these are cute."
And then like the next morning, I was like,
"Those aren't cute.
"Those are cute."
But you kept 'em.
I kept 'em because maybe there'll be cute one day.
They're like a Doc Martin, but like a platform.
What am I doing?
Like I'm going to a rave.
That is so not you.
No, no.
I have this really bizarre,
it's my favorite store in New York City.
If you're ever in town, please go to Abracadabra.
They have vintage stuff.
It's like a dream, everything you could ever imagine.
And I got this crazy head dress with horns and feathers
and pearls that go.
And I just keep it in there because every once in a while,
it's just time to put that thing on.
Yes, and do a walk around the house.
And you would see it in the closet and you're like,
"Oh okay, that's an outlier."
And yet I love supporting it whenever I can.
What about you?
Anything rando in your closet?
I have a leather black and white cowboy jacket
with tassels all up and down the back.
Yeah!
Oh my God.
Hey, I'll trade you a pair of boots for that jacket.
I want that.
Or maybe you need to put your boots
and the jacket together.
With your head dress.
We got a look.
Well Malik, I would love to see you in that jacket.
Thank you everybody
for choosing to spend your time here with us.
We make this show for you.
(audience clap)
So, take it with you!
Take it with you!
(upbeat music)